she says Michael your your grandfather
is not doing well he's 92 right it would
be so terrific though if if before he
died he could turn on the television and
see you doing something that looked like
work here we are in the Sunday special
with Mike Rowe we'll get to talking with
him he's the host of dirty jobs and the
way I heard it it'll be awesome but
first let's talk about your impending
death so you're going to die sometime
soon maybe not that sumit hopefully
it'll be decades but when you do you're
gonna feel bad because you didn't have
life insurance 71% of people say they
need life insurance only 59% of people
have coverage that means at least 12% of
people are procrastinating and sure
normally procrastinating is a bad thing
but if you've been avoiding getting life
insurance procrastinating may actually
have worked in your favor this time
because you're not dead and well you
were putting it off policy genius was
making it easy so policy genius it's the
easy way to compare life insurance
online you can compare quotes in just
five minutes when it's that easy putting
it off becomes a lot harder you can
compare quotes while sitting on the
couch you can do it while you're
listening to this podcast try it policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage they don't
just make life insurance easy they also
compare disability insurance and renters
insurance and health insurance if you
care about it they can cover it so if
you need life insurance but you've been
putting it off because it's all a little
too confusing or you don't have the time
checkout policy genius it's the easy way
to compare top insurers and find the
best value for you no sales pressure
zero hassle and it's free policy
genius.com when it's this easy to
compare life insurance there's no reason
to put it off well Mike thanks so much
for coming by
really appreciate it that was terrific
thank you honestly you're the first
person who's ever praised the ads at the
beginning of the show so thank you for
that procrastination is the thief of
time I really thought you're going to
sneak it in there with that but kidding
aside I I love I love that there's no
daylight between you and the people who
make the program possible
it's it's refreshingly dare I say
authentic well thank you I appreciate it
because usually what I get is how dare
you interrupt these great conversations
with your money grabs and then I have to
remind people they're watching the show
for free because this is how commerce
operates yeah people don't like to be
reminded of that you see the filthy
lucre somehow pollutes what would
otherwise be a really wonderful series
of observations but now I'm afraid we
can't take you seriously because
somebody somewhere has decided to give
you some money I stretched I'm spent so
folks you can see why I love micro just
from the outset here but let's start
from the beginning so you now do this
podcast that's listened to by tens of
millions of people and you have various
billions billions ok billions people yet
unborn on planets that have not yet been
reached and you have the and you have
here your TV shows which have been
wildly popular you have books your mom
wrote a book they you but they've been
pressing lately you know all about her
mom and that's that's really fantastic
so how did you get from doing what you
were doing when you were 18 is this way
you saw yourself doing when you were 18
how did you get from point A to point B
Wow how long is this room it's about an
hour so okay so the short version is I
was convinced as a young guy growing up
in Baltimore that I would follow in the
footsteps of my grandfather who live
right next door my grandfather was a guy
who went to the seventh grade and then
he went to work by the time he was 30 he
was a master electrician after that he
mastered every other trade there was the
guy could build a house without a
blueprint he was that guy had the chip
right you just knew how to fix stuff
take your watch apart build your house
do whatever the handy gene tragically is
recessive so past me I didn't get that
and by the time I was out of high school
I realized that I would have to get a
different sort of toolbox
I learned to act sort of I learned to
sing a little bit and I I just looked at
a completely different way to go I
eventually got in entertainment kind of
Forrest Gump my way through the whole
landscape of narrating you know I
started narrating when I was really
young if there's a wildebeest trying to
get across the vast reaches of the
barren Serengeti but being slowly eaten
by crocodiles and and hyenas the odds
are decent that I'm telling you about it
sidenote it never works out for the
wildebeest right never leave the herd so
I started doing those things and like
frost says you know way leads on to way
and the next thing you know I'm
impersonating a host in front of various
cameras for various networks and one
show leads to the next and by the time I
was 42 I realize
that impersonating a host though I
become somewhat facile at it was not
nearly as rewarding as as telling the
unvarnished truth which dirty jobs was
it wound up being a attribute to my
granddad my mother my mother called me I
was working for CBS at the time 2001 I'm
in my cubicle and she says Michael it's
hosting a show called evening magazine
terrible show
she says Michael you're your grandfather
is not doing well he's 92 right I'm like
oh you know what do you think she said
maybe another year it would be so
terrific though if if before he died he
could turn on the television and see you
doing something that looked like work so
my mother calls me out when I'm about 42
dirty jobs began as a special for my
grandad people saw it 10,000 letters
came in you should meet my grandad
brother uncle cousin's sister aunt uncle
right and and so for 12 years I went
around the country profiling real people
who do real jobs that typically unfold
in real towns you can't find on a map
and that gave me a certain notoriety in
cable TV and way continued to lead on
two-way and a lot of other great things
have happened I have a foundation now
that focuses on closing the skills gap
and the podcast you mentioned has been
so much fun it's a writing exercise it
helps pass the time on planes their
short stories told in the style of Paul
Harvey's the rest of the story and while
I would never imagine for a moment I
could I could fill his shoes
it's been fun trying to follow in his
footsteps well it's all really fun stuff
to listen to and certainly fun stuff to
watch but it's also really meaningful
because you're one of the few people in
the entertainment industry who really
does take seriously the stuff that
people in the middle of the country are
doing and as the country sort of
polarizes between the folks who are in
the entertainment sphere or the
journalism sphere or the the sort of
high IQ is how they would term
themselves it's fear and the people who
are actually working the jobs that
actually get things done across
the country that that's a voice that
seems to have been lost a lot what do
you think is it do you think that's it
that's a really serious gap Ann do you
think that's a bridgeable gap or is that
is that gap between sort of the people
who deem themselves to be smart and the
people who deem themselves to be doing
jobs that matter that is that destined
to sort of increase as time goes on here
well there's always been a gap right
sometimes it's wide sometimes it's less
wide and we all fall in love with the
romantic version of ourselves right
whether you're a journalist or whether
you're an actor whether whatever it is
you think you are and whoever it is you
think you are that becomes you become
the Sun in your own solar system
so you everything else is just a planet
in orbit right so I think with regard to
the skills gap in regards to really any
gap it's all just symptomatic of a
series of what I would call disconnects
we've become slowly and inexorably and
profoundly disconnected from a lot of
very basic things that when I grew up I
was really connected to like where my
food comes from where my energy comes
from basic history basic curiosity you
know the things that fundamentally allow
us to assume a level of appreciation
that in my view is the best way to
bridge those gaps if we don't have
appreciation right if we're not if we're
not blown away by the miracle that
occurs when you flick the switch and the
lights come on if we're not gobsmacked
by flushing the toilet and seeing all of
it go away right when we start losing
our appreciation for those things the
gap deepens and I think the gap right
now is most extraordinary there's 6.3
million jobs that are available as we
speak we have 75 percent of those jobs
that don't require four-year degree and
yet we're still pushing the four-year
degree as the best path for the most
people and it just happens to be the
most expensive path and a lot of people
as you described who are kind of in the
middle have enough common sense to
realize that one
five trillion dollars in outstanding
student loans there's a version of
lending money we don't have to kids who
can't pay it back to training for jobs
that don't exist anymore and that's
crazy so you know I think there's great
common sense that is still alive and
well and a lot of people and I think
that as they look at the headlines
they're frustrated and to be fair I
think people on the coasts are coming at
it from their own bias and they're
frustrated and so a lot of frustrated
people are talking really loud past each
other
and a lot of truths are inconvenient for
a lot of people and so it just gets
noisy which is a long way of saying no I
don't think the gap will ever close I
I really don't but but I'm not freaked
out by that because I think the the
point is Sisyphean the point is quixotic
right so d let's talk about the college
thing for a minute because let's say
that you're somebody who's thinking
about going to college under what
conditions do you think somebody ought
to go to college and somebody who was a
Poli Sci major which is about the most
useless degree can have outside of like
lesbian dance theory or something then
my minor than that if you Poli Sci is
basically so you can go to law school
that's that's how poly SCI is and this
is true for what we at UCLA called North
Campus majors right all North Campus
majors was like English and poly SCI all
the liberal arts they all this stuff was
prepped for grad degrees or for getting
a low-level job in a newspaper or
something like that the South Campus
majors people were in the sciences and
maths those people were actually doing
something useful who do you think ought
to go to college especially because
there is a concomitant worry that if you
don't go to college and you go for one
of these blue-collar jobs that you're
talking about that don't necessarily
require a four-year degree that those
are you get automated in the in the near
future do you what do you think the
threat of that is and you have an
eighteen-year-old kid you tell him to go
to college or not concomitant
College word right I'd have gone with
contemporaneous but either way either
way those two see words leads to the
other C word which is curiosity no not
that one right look anybody who's
curious and who can afford it should go
to college the thing that I deal with
most often with my foundation which
focuses primarily on jobs that don't
require four-year degree that actually
exists when I come out in favor of those
opportunities what comes back over the
net usually with a lot of topspin is the
accusation that I'm anti college or anti
education I'm not my liberal arts degree
served me really really really really
well I got it in 1984 it was the product
of a two-year Community College and then
another couple years at a university and
when the dust settled the whole bill was
$9,800 same exact thing today is
eighty-eight grant right so my answer to
your question is hey can you afford it
if you can't don't know that doesn't
mean don't borrow money but if you don't
if you're not afflicted with a passion
for the major and you have to borrow 20
30 50 80 hundred thousand dollars in
order to pursue the thing you may or may
not be truly passionate about then I
don't know what to say to you other than
that has to be a function of either pure
pressure parental pressure were really
bad guidance counseling because I get it
it's not fair to compare a liberal
education to workforce development right
but at some point the only four-letter
word that truly matters is debt and you
can either do it or you can't I'll say
this to you know when I went to school
part of what you paid for was access a
big part of what you pay for right all
this information exists in obviously
libraries but mostly in the minds of
professors and you get access you sit in
front of them and you and you learned
well you know we have in our pockets
right now a device that gives us access
to 98% of the known information
world you can watch lectures from MIT
Yale Dartmouth William and Mary and all
the great schools for free I'm not
saying it's the same thing I'm just
saying that the cost of college is
unconscionable and and to to say that
questioning it is somehow fundamentally
you know out of bounds I just think it's
the it's the height of hubris so what do
we do
there there's a lot of talk pretty I
dove the political aisle right now about
the about the sort of falling down of
American industry supposedly this idea
that manufacturing is going away we're
moving toward a service economy that a
lot of these jobs are eventually going
to be automated or outsourced what do we
say to people who may not want to go to
college may want to get one of these
jobs worries that ten years from now
they're gonna be basically priced out of
the market by they want to be a trucker
and now there's gonna be Google trucks
on the roads
what do we do about that is there a
solution to that or is it just a matter
of human beings have to be adaptable
that you know I mean look when my
grandfather saw me mess up the
foundation and hang the drywall not
plumb you know he was very nice but
eventually eventually he just said look
you know you can be a tradesman if you
want to you just need a different
toolbox and it was really wonderful
advice in hindsight you know the idea
that I could work in Hollywood like an
electrician you know the ultimate
freelance really by the way the origins
of that word you're familiar with
freelance now it was literally a free
lance in medieval days you know you're a
knight who served whoever hired you
you're a mercenary mhm
well if you have a skill you can do that
because the skill goes wherever you go
what' question again anything question
was what do we do about the
manufacturing jobs that could be
disappearing is it something that the
government can solve or we tie is it a
trade problem is it a technology problem
or is it just gonna have to be people
adjusting as as time goes on what if
it's not a problem at all
what if it's simply the oldest
story in the world I mean I'm not a
history major but I read about the
Luddite revolution I read about what
happened in textiles I read about the
advent of looms and what that meant the
same exact argument then everybody
always says it's different this time
and maybe it is I don't know but
everybody always says it's different and
it almost never is in fact I don't think
it's ever been different so I don't know
I don't know what's a can I envision a
time when driverless cars and pilotless
planes are going all around I but I
think we'll live to see it I don't think
so I think we might I think you might
see a truck driving down the highway in
the next twenty years that's being
completely automated I also think you're
gonna see a human sitting behind the
wheel so okay so he's here you're just
optimistic in general about the
possibility that a lot of these jobs
will continue to exist because there's a
lot of pessimism from people like for
example we had aaron eric weinstein from
the from Peter Thiel's company last week
and he was deeply concerned about the
possibility as a lot of people are that
a lot of these blue-collar jobs are just
gonna go away and you're gonna have to
end up with some sort of universal basic
income or people who are not the
creatives end up not working but being
supported by the creatives because all
of these blue-collar jobs eventually
ends up being automated and and
destroyed over time I only answer that
first I'm gonna make an obscene profit
pitch so let's do that with all the
recent news about online security
breaches it's hard not to worry about
where my data goes making an online
purchase simply accessing your email
could put your private information at
risk you're being tracked online by
social media sites marketing companies
your mobile or Internet provider not
only can they actually record your
browsing browsing history they often
sell it to other corporations who would
like to profit from that information
which is why I've taken my privacy back
using expressvpn you do need a VPN and
expressvpn is the best they have easy to
use apps that run seamlessly in the
background of your computer phone and
tablet you turn on expressvpn with one
click an express VPN secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data hiding your public
IP address protecting yourself with
expressvpn it cost less than seven bucks
a month expressvpn is rated the number
one VPN service by TechRadar it comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee so if
you ever use public Wi-Fi and you want
to keep hackers and spies from seeing
your data expressvpn is
solution and if you don't want to hand
over your online history to internet
providers or data resellers expressvpn
is the answer protect your online
activity today find out how you can get
three months for free and expressvpn
comm slash gun that's expr ESS VPN comm
slash penny at three months free with
the one-year package expressvpn comm
slash band to learn more okay so it says
restate the question for those who
forgot it during that ad the basic the
basic question was a lot of folks right
now on both sides of the aisle are
worried about the bifurcation of an
economy where it becomes in what they
are calling now an IQ economy the idea
that if you are a creative type if
you're somebody who can do stuff that
machines can't do that artificial
intelligence can't do you'll have a job
in the future and you will and and your
job will be relatively safe and if you
are somebody who is working as a truck
driver that you're basically going to be
screwed and there isn't gonna be a lot
of job opportunity available to you do
you think that's something that's not
going to happen or if it does happen is
there a solution like universal basic
income that people are talking about
that's beyond my paygrade
I personally am very suspicious of that
simply because I you might solve a
financial problem but I think you're
gonna create some unintended
consequences
by essentially telling people that
here's a big pile of something that you
need and you don't have to do anything
for it I just think on a really
fundamental primal level you're moving
the cheese and I don't know what's gonna
come out the other side but I just can't
imagine it's gonna be good
you said bifurcated right I mean yes I
think spine is splitting it yeah exactly
I think it's a false choice you know I
think I I think heads and tails are
always going to be on the same coin and
this idea this idea that you're an
artistic left-brain person over here or
this non artistic right brain or what is
that you know I remember in the election
I think it was Rubio who talked about
more welders less philosophers which is
very much in keeping with with what my
foundation says right but only on a
practical need but i but i objected to
the idea that a welder can't quote
Nietzsche or Descartes right i mean III
object to the idea that a philosophy
for can't run an even bead down a seal
this idea that it's one or the other is
a very limited toolbox kind of thought
and I think what you said before is is
exactly right the answer to that
question is purely adaptive it's our
ability to adapt and to think more
broadly and to take more advantage of
the unlimited access that we all have to
the same bottomless compendium of
knowledge and it be excited by it to
explore that I just think part of the
solution has to start with curiosity it
has to the I don't have a magic 8-ball
and I have no idea what's truly coming
and I would never want to pretend to but
just because I can't tell you why I
think we're gonna be okay yeah doesn't
mean we're not mm-hmm we're gonna figure
it out because we always have and I'm
just very suspicious of the argument
says this this time we won't it's just
too complicated one of the things that
troubles me is when I look at the the
politicos I juice politics all day right
so when I look at the political
situation what I see from both sides is
this tendency toward seeing yourself as
a victim of general trends so on the one
side you have people who say we're
victims of racism or institutional
privilege and on the other side you have
people saying we're victims of foreign
trade and were victims of economic
development and people who say you
should put your own house in order first
seem to be getting a lot of flack for
that so as an example my friend Kevin
Williamson wrote for National Review he
wrote a piece specifically about some of
these dying towns in the Rust Belt that
were very heavily based on manufacturing
and factory work and he wrote this piece
basically saying if your town is dying
and you're sitting there waiting for
your job to come back you're being a
fool leave the town that goes somewhere
else it got all sorts of blowback and
somebody who's supposedly looking down
his nose at the working class and Kevin
grew up so poor that his mom was
stealing hangers from motels when he was
a kid
yeah is that something that we as a
people can overcome or is this just
endemic to human nature that we're
always gonna blame everybody else for
our own problems yeah we're always going
to blame people for our problems I mean
I think I think that's how we start I
think you know I mean we
don't come into the world in my view as
pure as we're often told I mean you have
kids right I mean you've got two kids
sitting next to each other once three
ones - they're playing this one wants
that toy this one doesn't want to give
the toy up so the one is over
it takes the toy maybe Bosch is the over
one over their head what I mean is this
is you know we come in covetous we want
we take a whatever it is it can't be our
fault we're where the Sun in our solar
system we're the center of our universe
you know how do we realize that we're
not you know it's kind of a clunky
analogy but but whatever it is that
allows us to assume in our infancy that
there's this somehow the universe has
come around us to take care of us that
translates to this idea that my town
can't die my job can't go away I had it
and now it's gone
and so timeout party foul not cool right
it's it's and so it's I don't mean it
all to make light of it and I read the
article that you're talking about
you got you got cream for that just
everybody yet and then he got cream
began exactly like cream cream right but
look we're outrageous for sale everybody
know no one knows it better than you I
don't think but finding a way to talk
about that issue along with many others
that doesn't immediately alienate half
the country is the thing that I look at
as a challenge every single day that's
what I do on my Facebook page that's
what I do with my foundation it's what I
try and do on shows like this I've spent
a lot of time on MSNBC CNN Fox I'll talk
to anybody who wants to have a fun
light-hearted yet grown-up conversation
and no matter where I go
people's heads explode there was a week
a few years ago where I I did I went on
a Glenn back and then two days later I
went on Bill Maher now I had three
million friends on Facebook
time a couple weeks later I had two
million you know my buddies on the right
just simply didn't know what to do with
the optics of me sitting next to Bill
Maher and my pals on the left just had
no notion of how to square the cognitive
dissonance that forced their heads to
explode when they saw me sitting there
with Glenn back just to know what to do
it it'll happen here it happens every
six months right so what I'm saying is
we're in the world
now where it's not it's not what we say
it gets us in trouble it's what we don't
and it's not where we are that makes
people's eyebrows arch it's who we're
sitting next to we're all it's it's it's
it's the proximity of outrage hey it's
the geography what do you think has
changed about that because I remember
five years ago I used to speak on
college campuses and I'd require any
security the outrage industry was there
obviously but it wasn't nearly at the
tenor that it is now where people are
digging through things people said ten
years ago to try and find the one thing
they said that they can get them fired
over and obviously you know now when I
go and speak at Berkeley I require 600
police officers where did all of this
come from like I just don't I don't
remember I remember people being very
angry during the Bush administration I
don't remember it being anywhere near
like this the level of anger that's in
the society is that some people have
attributed that to economics people have
attributed that to to cultural splits
where do you think that that that anger
is coming from well look I I hate to say
it but I I think part of it is social I
mean I have a show now on Facebook I'm
thrilled to be on that platform and my
show is a celebration of bloody
do-gooder ISM but I also own guns right
social is a tool guns are a tool and we
are right on the verge I think of
discovering some really interesting
parallels between the first and second
amendment and I think I think people are
people who would never ever consider or
associate a firearm with goodness are
ironically using speech as a as a real
cudgel and restricting it in in so
anyways the arguments are really
interesting you know and if if you look
at social as a weapon then it's a weapon
that you have you don't need a license
for it anybody can have it the question
is is how are you how are you going to
use it and most people simply don't have
the training or the maturity to handle
it and so the violence and the anger in
the outrage that you're seeing I think
in part as a result of having an
unlimited amount of access to a platform
that gives you both the mechanism to say
whatever you want and the anonymity and
the comfort to hide behind it and so
people are very shrill and they're very
brave in that and in those scenarios and
look all of that is just the portent to
it to a mob it all leads to sort of mob
mentality and I think that's what you've
probably you've probably seen things get
accelerated and then there's no place
left for it to go and so I have to act
out yeah conversations get shut down it
really is it's it's deeply unfortunate I
also think that you know that with the
rise of the social media and with the
rise of the technology I think there's
something else that's happened too and I
don't know where you are religiously or
where you get your values from but I
feel like there's a dramatic lack of
central values in people's lives the
people are now looking for value in the
anger that people feel fulfilled because
they're angry and the angry you are the
more fulfilled you are the more it shows
the or an authentic human being if
you're angry if you if you quell that
anger and actually have a regional
reasonable conversation with someone
this means you're inauthentic it means
you're hiding what you truly feel but if
you're really pissed off that means that
you are an authentic decent human being
and so more angry and indecent you are
the more decent you are by this but it's
perverse logic where do you think people
ought to get their values I mean your
values very practically based is it just
from how you grew up how is it is it
from a religious background where does
that come from I think you know it's a
nature nurture question right I mean
obviously it has a lot to do with how
you're raised but in the end you you
have to hit the reset button and really
decide for yourself not just what you
think but but why this confusion between
passion and conviction
what is there's a line I think it was
Yeats at the end of the best the the
best lack all conviction and the worst
are filled with passionate intensity yep
right so that's it if you don't have the
certainty of your convictions if you
can't make a case if you can't answer
the question you just asked me which
I'll try and get to in a sec then then
what is left you know nothing is left
but an explanation of how you feel and
so if your philosophy ultimately
redounds to an explanation of how you
feel then you're completely beholden to
whatever feeling you might be
experiencing at any given point and then
you're just one of those people who
follow their passion right good luck
with that personally I my philosophy has
a lot to do with being suspicious of
anything that feels easy just as a as a
general rule being wary of all
earnestness in the words of Travis McGee
John Dee McDonald one of my favorite
fictitious characters who in hindsight
actually formed the basis of my entire
business model and and gratitude you
know a good-natured skepticism a ton of
gratitude and you know some honest
intellectual curiosity will probably be
the best replacements least that I can
think of for getting right to the point
of let me tell you how I feel right I
really don't care how you feel honestly
I mean over a beer it's kind of fun
you're talking my language right here I
just don't care I mean it's it's it's
it's so much more interesting to
understand why you believe what you
believe than it is to hear about what
you believe and that's why mobs are
boring and that's why protests are
tiresome because all the placards just
simply say this is how I feel this is
what I believe yeah well one talk in a
second about some of the practical
hard-headed advice again we
yeah you bet it's happening right now
get ready for it I'm ready but first
let's talk about your sleep we're never
gonna agree on everything but I think we
can all agree that we can use more sleep
getting a great night's sleep is easier
and more affordable than you actually
think you don't need a new expensive
mattress or sleeping pills you need to
change your sheets that's why you should
check out bull and branch everything
bull and branch makes from its bedding
to blankets it's pure 100% organic
cotton means they start out super soft
and then they get even softer over time
you buy directly from them so you're
essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
bucks in the store bull and branch
sheets just a couple of hundred bucks
everybody who tries bull and brand
sheets loves them that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews and
Forbes Wall Street Journal Fast Company
they're all talking about bull and
branch even three u.s. presidents sleep
on bullying branch sheets shipping is
free you can try them for 30 nights so
no risk if you don't love them send them
back for a refund but you're not gonna
want to send them back there's no risk
no reason not to give them a try to get
you started right now my listeners get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets at
bull and branch calm promo code Ben
guess because I have a guest go to bull
and branch calm today for 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets
that's bol el and branch calm promo code
Ben guest bull and branch calm promo
code Ben guest alright well we're back
and I can feel my wallet just got this
much fatter I just happened yeah and
mine is gone and it's because I keep
buying everything I mean this is how to
make my money so I'm glad if I can if I
can get micro to fall for my
advertisements I mean I can get anyone
but how many times are you accused of
selling out on this Sunday special like
every Twitter every comment on the
YouTube video below every single one I
see ok so people say when I run for
presidents and my inauguration will
begin fellow Americans but first an ad
from Birch gold like this is this is
really what all the comments say below
this video right here right now so I get
it I get it every week right it's just
that people it's their heads explode
when they when this weird mix of like
like Commerce and art dare we say our
you know collide they come together in
this happy nexus of serendipity and yet
it's it's mind-boggling to people my
first job in TV was at a home shopping
channel I sold out before I had anything
to bargain so
I mean I'm I was serious before when I
said I I really applaud what you're
doing because it is you this show is
utterly without pretense I have no idea
what you're gonna ask me next and the
only thing more liberating than that is
I'm convinced that you don't either
except we're gonna stop every 15 seconds
to take care of the brute realities of
keeping these or these lines and they
are acting these lights are and so look
I I you you use the word authenticity
before in a couple of different ways I
think it's one of the most important
concepts going right now because the
country starved for it
starved for it but we're not quite sure
what it is but it has something to do
with the way you're doing this well I
think I appreciate that I think that the
authenticity break is actually it has
something to do with the election of
President Trump I think to get political
you know the we would rather have an
authentic quasi con man in the White
House and we would have an inauthentic
harpy like like Hillary Clinton we would
much rather have somebody who is
actually the person that he says he is
like everybody knows what Trump is at
this point everything is baked into the
cake with President Trump because we
because he's just out there about it
like pretty much you could hit him with
anything at this point and he would
probably survive it he's like a
cockroach after a nuclear explosion he's
going to survive it and that's not
that's meant in the best possible way he
is a political I mean when I say
cockroach after a nuclear explosion I
don't mean that as bad as it sounds I
mean that it's a quality in a politician
that is hard to come by
don't Plantin had it too but the sort of
feeling like we can trust you because we
know that what you're saying is what you
actually believe is something that that
is is really effective right now given
how produced everything is because
everybody is so afraid these social
media mobs authenticity is in short
supply what do you make of Trump how did
he come about and and what have you made
of him so far so it was the question on
everybody's mind on everything I
understand he's the son around which the
universe revolves yep look I was on I
was invited on Meet the Press the Sunday
after the election and they asked me
that same question because a couple
weeks earlier I was asked that question
on Facebook and I answered it very
candidly I said he's gonna win he's
gonna win running away I wish I'd
listened to you I lost a bunch of money
on the election now there's no doubt
about it
I mean for me look I just spent ten
years in Wisconsin Michigan western
Pennsylvania I'll throw it you know I
mean it was to me from what I saw it was
obvious but I'll tell you my Trump story
all right I mean I've got it I've got a
few of them but but the one that was
public I raised money for my foundation
and a lot of unorthodox ways you know
for years I had these things called crap
auctions collectibles rare and precious
and I I would I would go in my garage
and I would take on a piece of crap that
I'd accumulated in my dirty travels
right and I would sell it in the QVC
style and I'd give the money we raised
to the foundation we raised hundreds of
thousands of dollars so when the
election was at his fevered pitch I had
a show on CNN at the time called
somebody's got to do it and the show is
no longer on CNN it's actually on TBN
had to move it because it was preempted
constantly because the election ramped
up in such a way so I I went online and
I and basically said to Donald Trump
Hillary Clinton and Bernie Sanders had
nice gone guys you just got my show
booted off the network I'll forgive you
if each of you will make a donation to
my foundation what I'm looking for from
you Bernie is you're one of those
crumpled you know suit coats you always
wear send that to me and I'll auction it
off Hillary send me one of your pants
suits right and I said to Trump I said
send me one of your bathrobes and an
autograph you know a bathrobe out here
so heard nothing from Bernie Sanders
heard nothing from Hillary Clinton
Donald Trump sent me an autographed
bathroom with his name signed on it he
had a hand delivered to me
so the next next week I put on his
bathrobe and I sit down at my kitchen
table you know I got my iPhone set up
and I'm doing an episode of crap I
auction this thing off got $18,000 for
it it's like that okay so I got a lot of
he for wearing a Donald Trump bathrobe I
don't care the money went straight to
the work ethic scholarship program the
moral of the story is he understands
who's watching and he understands what's
happening it doesn't have anything to do
I don't know I can't speak to his
polemics his politics I don't need to
say anything to get myself in any more
hot water
he sent the robe nobody else did and I
really I really didn't expect him to but
a deal's a deal so I auctioned it off
and I thanked him and the money went to
a great cause my only other interaction
with him
we got a call months ago from from the
White House to talk about supporting a
thing that just happened this week this
big initiative around vocational
education Duncan trumps been pushing
that yeah her people called and we had a
really candid conversation and look I'll
tell you what I told him I said look I'd
love to
I mean honestly I'd love to because what
what you're talking about is the mandate
of micro works it's what I've been I
mean from the day Barack Obama when in
office we started our foundation Labor
Day 2008 were 10 years this year and uh
I've been to the extent that I'm able to
call for anything I've been calling for
this exact thing a PR campaign for good
jobs and actually exist and a genuine
focus on alternatives to a four-year
education but I said look I if I put on
and make America great hat
half the country will not hear me and so
it has nothing to do forget my personal
politics do what you can politically
what I'm doing now is not political at
all it's one of the few areas I believe
right and left still share with these
Venn diagrams there's not a lot of
shared real estate left but the
definition of a good job in 2018 is
something we're all gonna have to figure
out
and look I call it as I see him what
they did this week around the skills gap
as you would say good trial mm-hmm
so what so tell us a little more about
vocational training you know as somebody
who went to the Toni colleges and and
has can barely pick up a hammer what is
what is vocational training actually
constitute because when I hear it it
sounds like a welding shop class from
middle school or something what exactly
what exactly is it and why should people
undergo it if they if they're seeking a
job in one of these industries
vocational training is the is the most
direct line you can find between where
you are now and an actual opportunity
it's it's job training it's it's not
esoteric it's not theoretical it's this
is what you need to be able to do in
order to get money for doing it it's
very very simple and it can apply to
it's not just well during and steam
fitting and pipe fitting and things like
that is this healthcare areas there's so
many opportunities that require
vocational training but the first thing
to understand is what you just said it
is exactly right the language matters
the language matters hugely and you know
shop class we didn't just get shop class
out of high school like that it was a
process shop used to be called
vocational arts the first thing we did
was we took the art out of it and then
we made it vote tech and then it was
just vocational education and that
eventually it became shop at which point
it's easy to walk it out back behind the
barn and put a bullet in its head and
that's what we did we took shop class
out of high school is there a more
persuasive way to show an entire
generation of kids what's important than
by eliminating it from view and well and
the entertainment industry has
contributed to this also I mean like
every joke is always about shop class
every joke is always about the guy who's
the plumber the the ideal that you
aspire to if you watch TV is never the
person who actually is working one of
the jobs that you're talking about it's
always a lawyer or a doctor those are
the glamorous jobs apparently nobody
ever actually tossed a lawyer a doctor
before making the show
about lawyers and doctors being glorious
jobs because as a lawyer and with wife
is a doctor it is not a clear it's job
it actually turns out but the internet
ministry obviously circulated in in New
York and LA made up a bunch of people
like me people who can't handle a hammer
what does how does Hollywood contribute
to to this sort of skills gap and
problem do you think mightily you know
you're talking about a cold war on work
and it's waged on multiple fronts
Hollywood leads the charge to your point
if there's a plumber on a show he's 300
pounds with a giant butt crack
that's what plumbers look like right all
of them are the recipients not of a
skilled trade but of some kind of
vocational consolation prize it's what
you do if you can't do this right so
that's the working assumption and
Hollywood has confirmed those stigmas
and stereotypes in a multitudinous
number of ways Madison Avenue has done
the exact same thing you see the same
poor trails in advertising as you do in
popular culture books I mean look I
I'm pals with Tim Ferriss but you know
we always laugh and we talk about this
because when he published the 4-hour
workweek it was one of the first
examples I pointed to there's a great
bestseller it's full of good advice but
the titular promise is how to get so
much more by doing so much less all the
propositions on any financial ad that
you're ever going to see or read are
going to it's pregnant with the
possibility of retiring sooner working
less if you're unhappy the proximate
cause of your unhappiness probably has
to do with the damn boss or your damn
job that's how you make work the enemy
you identify it as the reason for your
unhappiness and then you juxtapose it
with all kinds of other images that you
that you can't have right and now you
now you have a whole new gap in there so
my foundation evolved really as a PR
campaign for jobs that actually
exist and a challenge to this idea that
you know the most expensive path was the
best path for the most people so yeah I
I have lots of opportunities and lots of
examples because this town is rife with
it but look it's everywhere Ben it's a
it is on bookshelves it's on your
television and and it's in parents look
then and this goes back this is the
reptilian part of our brain we want
something for our kids better than we
had doesn't matter how good we had it
that matter because we want something
better that's okay that's that's normal
but at some point back to defining what
a better job or a good job really is
parents can't agree guidance counselor's
can't agree guidance counselors in high
schools now in many cases are are
evaluated and comped based on their
ability to help X number of students
matriculate into a four-year school
that's the goal right so we've we've got
our thumb on the scale in so many
different ways and ultimately what we're
left with is a giant hot massive
misunderstanding myths stereotypes and
misperceptions that are affirmatively
keeping people from pursuing a litany of
opportunities so one of the things that
I love that you talk about is is the
meaning of work one as you say there are
a lot of folks in our society who seem
to think that less work is is better and
that retiring early is the thing and
then you see all these people who retire
at age 66 and by 68 they're dead because
if you're not working then you're not
doing anything I am it's been my view
for my entire life that people were
legitimately born to work until you die
and even if you don't have work you find
things to work at whether it's you go
and you volunteer somewhere you're
working with the charity people need to
feel purpose and people find purpose in
work but you have a you have an
interesting perspective on this because
the way that I was brought up you know
in the schools that I went see the way
that I think people of my generation
were brought up is find something that's
meaningful and then try to find a job in
the thing that you find meaningful where
is one of the things you preach is find
a job and then try to find meaning in
that job which is kind of polar opposite
you can you
talk about that a little bit well look I
mean in the end what you want is
meaningful work and let's define
meaningful work as as an activity that
you're passionate about that moves the
needle in in some way and that
compensates you in a way that excites
you the question is how do you get there
and today the path starts with passion
it starts with well sit down and think
about it what would make you happy
what do you see yourself as doing right
identify that thing now let's put
together a plan what sort of education
do you need how much time should it take
and you put all these hoods in front of
it right and now and now you have a plan
and when you get to that place
congratulations you've done it right
that's insane right that's insane
it's kind of like saying Ari you want to
be happy and you're and you're in your
love life all right are you going to go
in search of your soul mate or are you
going to go where the people are and
start getting to know them and it's just
it just depends on how hard you want to
make so one of the big lessons from
Dirty Jobs was the people on that show
collectively were having a much better
time than the average person would
suspect they would be having given the
fact that most of them were covered in
other people's crap we're crawling
around in some godforsaken pit of
despair we're doing some vocational
consolation prize thing right these
people aren't supposed to look happy
they're not supposed to look
self-actualized they're not supposed to
look prosperous the dirty little secret
of dirty jobs was that easily 40 of the
people we featured on that show were
multimillionaires we never talked about
it because I didn't want it to be a
polemic but success doesn't look like
the version we've been sold at all at
all so you know having fun with that
that kind of cognitive dissonance is is
great showing
people examples of the plumber who began
his or her trade with learning a skill
and now had seven trucks and 32
employees that's important those people
over and over again the septic tank
inspector up in West Wisconsin the the
skull cleaners in in Oklahoma City I can
go down the list
none of them set out to do what they
were doing
none of them began with what would make
me happy these people looked around to
see where everybody was running and they
ran in the opposite direction that's
where they found opportunity then they
found a way to get good at it
then they learn their trade and then
they they mastered it then they found a
way to be passionate about it so they
got to the same place but they didn't
start on this snipe hunt of what will
make me happy they looked around and
said where the jobs and they got him and
do you think the weird question for you
do you think that same thing applies in
personal relationships 100% I think it
applies in everything I think you know
our brain is obviously our our best
friend and our and our worst enemy you
know it it'll do whatever we tell it to
do right I mean if you assign it a task
it's gonna go until it can complete it
we're die trying just be careful of what
you assign it to you know I mean if you
if you tell your brain the only way
you're going to be happy is if you find
your soul mate you better be prepared to
embark upon a worldwide never ending
tour of chronic disappointment it's
gonna be expensive right
I'm not saying settle see it's another
binary choice this is what people are
gonna say to me well they don't be like
so you're just saying just go buy just
what arranged marriages well I don't
know but statistically arranged
marriages do pretty good you know they
do pretty good so I'm not saying that I
know you're right in the sense that you
know there's also talk about passion
nowadays passion and marriage and what
the social science tends to show
is that passion in in any relationship
is it it's very high at the very
beginning and companionate love is it
it's very low and then in very short
order passionate love drops
precipitously in companionate love
increases precipitously and so you can
bet on passionate love but no matter how
you bet I'm passionate love within a
year that passionate love is gonna be
declining question is why the
companionate love is actually going to
last and so if you go into it exactly if
you go into it with the mentality that
this is something you're gonna have to
stick to the chances you have a
successful marriage are gonna be a lot
better than I'm gonna go into it because
I'm passionate about it because every
job eventually becomes a job no matter
how passionate you are about your
initial belief in a job and I love my
job and I'm sure you love your job
eventually it gets to the point where
yeah I got to get up this morning gotta
go to work right still you getting up
and going to work happiness is a it's a
it's a terrific symptom it's a terrible
goal right it's just a terrible goal
because it's a it's a sucker's bet if it
were if happiness were that tangible
than everything the same thing would
make everyone happy but obviously it it
doesn't you know but I just I'm sure of
that I'm not sure if much but I'm I'm
sure of that
I wrote this thing you'd get a kick out
of it it's a it started like most
everything I do as an attempt to amuse
myself but after a bottle of wine one
night you know I'm my foundation Awards
work ethic scholarships so we need to
have some mechanism by which we can try
to account for work out I mean how do
you measure character it's virtually
impossible but I wrote this thing called
a sweat pledge skills and work ethic are
not taboo aren't above sweat right and
you have to sign it it's a 12-point
pledge sort of part 12-step process part
Scout law right and and some people
really really really hate it but one of
the first things is you know you know
I'm I'm grateful I won the greatest
lottery of all time I I live in America
too I do not follow my passion right at
3:00 I make it goes down all of these
things it was just it was like a little
personal manifesto for me but I only
bring it up because it's become
increasingly more important to my
foundation and now the more I look back
on it it's hysterical been how how
outraged people get yeah I give away
I mean maybe 5 million dollars so far
right not a ton by foundation standards
but it's a ton on en every year about
eight hundred thousand dollars goes out
and every year people say well why do I
have to sign the sweat lodge and I said
well you don't have to it's entirely
possible this particular pile of free
money might not be for you I mean there
are many scholarship funds that award
academic achievement I'm more interested
in or in awarding attendance right
I mean athletic achievement talent
they're there all kinds of rubrics and
metrics for measuring value but where's
the work ethic so that's what we try and
do and forgive me I'm trying to bring
this back to the answer to the question
you posed but I forgot what it is again
so if I mean I think you took me on the
journey and now now we're left adrift
here but they were sweat pledge I'm
gonna send you a sweat pledge okay
sounds good well and let's hone in on
for a second the first principle do you
mention which is that you won the
lottery because you live here which is
something with which I totally agree but
that's a pretty controversial
proposition these days sure and it's
it's become almost partially a
left-right proposition unfortunately
where you see there's a poll that came
out just within the last month it
suggested that Republicans particularly
we're very proud to be members of the
United States very proud to be American
and they were very proud to be American
when Obama was president this was not
dependent on who was president it was
73% of Americans where Republicans were
proud when Obama was president at 77%
now and for Democrats was like 54% were
positive when it was Obama and now it's
like 38% because of President Trump why
do you think there are so many people in
the country who look at the situation
that they've been handed which is the
freest most prosperous country in the
history of humanity and and think to
themselves I'm a victim in this scenario
and that not to discount anybody's
actual
hardships are past but why do you think
that that's become such a prominent
thing and what clearly is a land of
opportunity because it's not clear it's
not clearly right the big of all the
divides the one that worries me the most
is the divide between people who are
genuinely genuinely convinced that
opportunity is dead and those who are
not right
the ones who are artificially convinced
or just you know paying lip service to
it they don't matter but there are a lot
of people who really and truly truly
believe the system is rigged and they
truly believe opportunity is dead that's
how they scare me not because I'm
frightened of them but because that
belief is that that'll kill us I mean if
that belief really truly spreads it will
kill us this is why the skills gap
becomes weirdly political it's it
shouldn't be
it's just opportunity it's just six
point three million jobs sitting there
vacant but when I point that out it's
it's very difficult because everything
is politicized today right it's what
comes back is well what does the
existence of opportunity mean in a
country where we're fighting over the
fact that opportunity may or may not be
dead it's proof positive that it's not
now that's a problem right the optics
don't line up so then you have economic
experts with whom I I really can't
engage because I'm not an economist but
they will tell you why the skills gap is
a myth so here's how it breaks down
if I point to six million available jobs
my friends on the right will tell me
that those jobs are available because
human beings are fundamentally lazy my
friends on the Left will tell me that
those jobs are available because
employers are fundamentally greedy and
that's where we are we can't think
beyond the fact that our basic
philosophies require us to see humanity
as either lazy or greedy now the truth
is in my opinion
we're both lazy and greedy right and
we're neither lazy nor greedy we're all
of it and none of it and all of it gets
measured out in unequal amounts but we
don't we don't have time today to parse
the nuance of that it simply has to be
one or the other so when I post a
picture of me standing next to the flag
on the 4th of July I got a lot of
pushback and I think a lot of people who
were pushing me back don't really want
to push back they just don't want to see
me doing something patriotic because the
lines have been drawn and now if you're
if you're patriotic well then you must
be on the right that's also really super
dangerous
it's a it's a false choice and and we
have to push back against that we it's
incumbent upon us I think you're doing a
decent job of it
I'll try Thanks I mean no honestly look
yours biased as I am yours biases the
next person but you can point these
cameras at anything you want and you're
you're pointing them at honest
thoughtful conversation
well thanks let's let's talk a little
bit about you have a unique perspective
on life what are your parents like and
this gives you the opportunity all about
your mom because you have a brand-new
book that your mom has written that
you're pushing right now so what were
your parents like well they're they were
a lot like what happily they still are
oh good okay so yeah my dad is 86 years
old thank god he delivers meals on
wheels once sometimes twice a week and
he volunteers at the hospital once a
week my mom is 80 she still sings in the
church choir and she and she writes
every day she's been writing me letters
for as long as I can remember I started
reading them online and people started
saying you should write a book and so
she has she wrote a book called about my
mother if I were you right now you know
what I'd do I'd say I'm gonna ask you
that question real quick but first about
my mother a hero it's available at micro
dot-com slash mom's book Jack about
it'll change your life
and it will and I mean look never mind
what the book is about
I mean it's 14 short stories and they're
all terrific and anybody who's ever been
a mother or a daughter will love it
what's amazing as my mom has written a
book at 80 she's 80 years old and just
decided I want to write a book and it's
good and you know I'm so proud of her
because he'll man I people half her age
with way more opportunity and and they
don't she did a thing you know my
parents are both completely engaged with
the world around them and still in love
with each other so here's a final
question for you before we have to run
grit an opportunity and and opportunism
and an enthusiasm and curiosity these
are all the things that you like to talk
about do you think these are inborn
qualities and people are these things
that you can cultivate or is it a little
bit of both because obviously there are
some people who there's a case may that
there are some people who just can't get
over that hump and there are some people
who are automatically benefited from
birth with with these qualities how much
of it can be cultivated and how much of
it is just that's the way you are I
think all of it can be cultivated I
really do look I think it's I think
change is the hardest thing but to our
earlier point we come into the world
utterly selfish completely dependent and
totally totally at the mercy of the
people around us you know if we don't
change from that then then obviously
right so yeah you can cultivate in a an
outlook of gratitude you can cultivate
opportunism you can also cultivate
hypocrisy and you can cultivate
smallness and and meanness and it's it's
I believe some people will always have
it easier of course nobody's starting
from the from the same starting line
it's okay
it's never been that way but it's a
hundred percent up to us where are we
finished
well micros it's such a pleasure to have
you here and I really appreciate your
time everybody should go check out your
podcast they should check out your mom's
book everything that you're doing and
what's the best way to reach you with
your website I'm on Facebook I got micro
comm hard to miss go check it out micros
awesome thanks so much for stopping by
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jess wa al Vera entitle graphics by
Cynthia and Gullu the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018